Justin Timberlake was snapped holding
hands with his Palmer co-star Alicia
Wainwright yeah you heard me Justin
who's been married to Jessica Biel for
seven years was spotted on a balcony
overlooking Bourbon Street holding hands
with another woman
oh man but it's okay guys you can all
calm down because the source tells ET
the moment was totally innocent the
source who was with Justin and Alicia at
the New Orleans bar the absinthe house
tells et that this was just a casual
nothing to talk about nothing to see
here gathering of friends cast and crew
nothing more period Alicia's rap double
down on that sentiment telling ET quote
there is no validity to the speculation
a second source tells ET that Justin and
Alicia are like brother and sister and
the Hangout was harmless the two are
currently in the Big Easy shooting the
movie Palmer together and in the pics
that have literally everyone talking
they can be seen holding hands and she
even has her hand on the singers knee
the two play love interests in the flick
where Justin portrays a former high
school football star who returns to his
hometown following a prison sentence
here he is on set in what looks like a
prison uniform his character eddie
palmer finds himself becoming the ward
to a young boy who was abandoned by his
mother and alicia plays Maggie Hayes a
schoolteacher who developed some feels
for Eddie so just who is Alicia the
thirty year old actress starred in
Shadowhunters I just wanted something
that would get vampires excited about
coming to a former werewolf hunt and can
currently be seen in Netflix's raising
Deon
but get this guy's before she was an
actress Alisha studied botany at the
University of Florida yeah you know like
plants she furthered her career in
science and moved to Panama after
graduation to conduct field research in
preparation for a PhD anyway that did
not last but according to her Instagram
the girl loves to travel and can kick
some serious butt oh and she's in a
relationship of her own but our source
says Alicia is keeping her partner's
identity private as for Justin he and
Jessica Biel have been married since
2012 and share a four-year-old son Silas
now a source tells ZT Jessica and Justin
love each other dearly they want nothing
more than to stay together and even
though Justin works and travels a great
deal and he is so much in the public eye
both Jessica and Justin are wonderfully
dedicated parents who both have careers
which can present some challenges justin
recently opened up to ET about their
marriage and how they make it work it's
just it does it's uh it's like that that
once you find that person that's like a
baptism where you're like I can't go
back you know that I mean like I don't I
can't go back so which is what
fatherhood's like too of course
ET will be here to bring you all the
latest on justin so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens see you soon
[Music]